little brother is the name of this
episode Jake back that off I didn't make
the sound everything's gonna be the
sound he didn't banks encouraging um
okay so movies uh this is an episode
where she'll be during a party
accidentally gets his butt cut off and
makes a little brother and name wasn't
originally bug emic buck buck and he
calls him well was it buddy uh butter
butter butter butter but now that was
buggy something was butter me but he
calls him Kent something has nothing to
do with any of the big names we were
trying to emulate what something's gone
really you're gonna work it out K
whatever um so that's it's his but yes I
thought he's also a bug so I thought I
had something to do with that
but regardless uh he goes and buddy but
erson buddy but erson but t vzy
Punderson okay I wasn't I thought was
buggy buggers you and your bugs me like
bugs so he doesn't know what to do with
them so he asked Jake for some advice
cuz you know if it Fitness his brother
and pretty much he says I'll just give a
sword and tell him to kill things so he
does exactly that says go find things to
kill so he goes into the wall finds
those a bunch of those rats and other
little bugs and just goes on this creepy
quest and he comes across these other Oh
what are those thea the rats Ravi Singh
Rathore with the others the we beard and
stuff things living in the just things
okay just other things and he goes on
these many quests to make like the the
perfect sword and he gets in a they
offer him stuff but he has no idea what
they really are cuz he's only a few
minutes old so he decides to go get the
sword fight off all these evil rats that
make one giant rat is this great big
epic adventure and then Shelby starts to
miss him but he comes back they sing a
little song and then he goes off to
adventure more because he feels that's
where he belongs and
the first time ever the tree and the
tree is spring actually what it
blue-blue yeah cuz the the curse must
take it off of it um and yeah it the
first thing that came in my head I'm
worried about different you to remember
when he winks yeah oh yeah Sparrow
Prince little gerbil that gets shoved up
a guy's ass and it's just like there's
another episode going on but just
everyone's well cut back to him and his
adventures in the ass pretty much it's
like it's just something I clearly
should not be this epic grand adventure
but it is this case uh it's got the same
idea it's just this very tiny little
okay not in an ass but house and just
goes on this great big grand adventure I
have served the mystical elements and
you know if you had to make a choice and
who is the most true and most worthy and
you know and if fighting off this great
big villain at the end and going outside
quest yes so it was fun and it was night
the little Kent is very cute and I like
a little song that she'll be enhancing
at the end and even the end had sort of
like this like I said like you were
served the end of a great big adventure
I really felt like this is what in a
strange way what the lemonhope episodes
were trying to do because when I got to
that end with the tree bloom et Cathal
yeah that feels completed that feels
like the whole feel of this episode was
this quest and in the quest they usually
have a story of this is how this lent at
bat you know something we know everyday
and it just felt very fitting and ya
know I thought was fun I thought was
there's a good jokes it was creative so
I definitely dug it dug yes that's the
only reason why you liked that movie up
did you I want Jason it was it adjacent
to your thoughts
it's from the movie was terrible no I
liked the episode this episode was fun
um I loved how Kent just popped out
Arden's how'd you do that
I'll play this and hit and then she'll
be like I was expecting like a fart or a
poop or something and nothing happened
after that little bit kind of funny um I
I thought it was fun overall like it's
it has some RPG elements there of course
gathering you know certain artifacts and
whatnot yadda yadda yadda but yes first
in the buff that my damn head was love
you in that space yep you saw the rat
yeah that right that's the first it
popped my damn head was let me wink I
bet they all sort of have high-pitched
sped-up voices too yeah I mean it's kind
of impossible not to think of it but I
think it still works I didn't see it's
like oh ripoff per se oh yes don't felt
like its own thing that was cute
in me if anything may have been a tiny
nod to it yeah um I thought it was just
a fun cute little episode all and all I
liked looking at it the Rat King was
voiced by the guy who did dr. venture
which when I read that I was like what
and then I heard it I'm like oh god I
can actually hear it that's really
creepy
I did like the design of the Rat King
yeah he's a bunch of other little rats
what does he like done before like
there's numerous cases of that happening
but I really liked how it was done in
this where like it was all in shadow and
then like like you saw his fist and he
said like just the top of was the mind
yeah and it's the light from the sword
that was lighting them up and yeah
that's pretty cool um I wasn't a huge
fan of the song especially like the
beginning part it felt awkward
it felt kind of forced they always kind
of feel a bit awkward and out of nowhere
there no don't think they just come out
of nowhere and that's part of the
thought about it I don't think so I mean
like when they started singing together
I thought it felt a lot better but like
just she'll be singing alone felt really
odd you know they really reminded me on
what if you get this - um I don't know
if is intentional but remember in
Snoopy come home when you see him
doesn't win which I've singing the song
and that Snoopy comes in at the end and
they start singing the song together
even though in the end of them can talk
do you never see some newbie come home
is that the bloomery leaves to go see
his family
no this is a la girl that's sick his
previous owner no I never saw that one
oh it's so good really it's so friggin
good what is it better than great race
Charlie Brown
otherwise for you like Charlie Brown I
think it is but I I know a lot of people
that hold like a real connection to that
for that one which I think it's one of
the lesser Christmas I mean Thanksgiving
Oh Gary outside tractor Oh go see that
I'll lend it to you okay yeah if you
haven't either go check another Sherman
Brothers do the songs oh no it they're
unbelievably good songs because there's
the one where Snoopy goes home to where
he was born
nyan odds are different okay huh so oh
no I I mean that's possible that that
could be a reference or nod yeah I mean
it's probably not but God I think
there's other things that had them worse
like somebody sing and then somebody
returns or comes back in singing the
song and then they sing it together I
mean I'm sure them whatever did Snoopy
and Woodstock actually have voices no
they whistled you know they whistled is
one thing okay they would you know as
good be cool yeah no it was actually it
was really cool I
I love the Trumpkin party in the viola
though yeah especially like Shelby just
apparently wasted and just falling and
lopping off his button he's like oh man
I did something stupid
Shelby's always a character when I see
him I sort of think oh okay Shelby
episode whatever but then I'm I'm always
laughing with him I'm always like no
this is fun like this is a good episode
with him nobody's always great yeah I
don't know why every time I see him
maybe because he is a worm I just always
think oh yeah the life of a worm
it's like they're usually pretty funny
and is the the voice and the delivery is
really funny so yeah it's good
who could be hula was it who could be
worse off than him right now me watching
him yeah I thought it was I thought
responding it was interesting and yeah I
will never get lemmiwinks out of my head
you will get out of a few other places
I'm sure too any closing thoughts
no no well guys this is gonna be the
last one for a while not that we're
gonna stop all together but I mean we've
gotten to the point where you know now
we're sort of watching them the same
time you guys are watching them we had
to wait for them to come out so we can't
just watch them in bulk so like it I
don't know exactly how it'll work cuz
it's I mean maybe I could just always
drive out here for one episode I'll get
my love coming up there love seeing you
guys so but bottom line we'll still keep
doing the episode it's kind of like how
Rob and I do like the core of be logs
and stuff so if they'll keep going it's
not like an official end or anything but
serve like the everyday thing we're not
gonna keep going um I don't know if I'm
gonna do another show I was kind talking
to Mike Mashhad about them you were
saying like just just do it if one like
really comes to your mind like you
really want to do um and I can't think
of anything Ora don't worry the Explorer
yes we will make this happen let's talk
about the symbolism of Dora oh we can
learn along the way well what does he
mean I'm the map does it mean to be a
map but remember Swiper no swiping
the Det sorry I probably learned a spin
you oh I mean actually would be very
educational it's an alien language Oh
Terry um French sure but yeah so I don't
know I'm like there's one show I was
thinking about doing but I mean I won't
give it away in case I do it um I wasn't
no it's not
little by little and I will say this too
cuz I'm actually wrapping up Breaking
Bad I'll do one be log Joe stop Breaking
Bad in general because everyone's always
like do Breaking Bad be logs and I'm
like it's a really good show and I have
stuff to say about I can't do episode by
episode I not that there's not a lot to
talk about but it's not like you know
I'm dying to talk about or I can talk
like in a bunch of layers like the
interest is not there is life I can't
talk about the series like it one go so
I'll get that
but I'll rig it up into season like one
episode per season one oh I'd be five
episode well you know therefore you
don't have to try to cram so much in no
but I can I can make it gonna be nice
well stop it you've been nice enough
letting me come here and do the V logs
and enjoy the beautiful family that they
are beautiful
chari three you're beautiful people what
about my cat he's okay
kill it nor to have kill or sleep yeah
he didn't open his eyes no um I do want
to say though even though this isn't
like the last one or anything but I
really do want to say I mean like I
start off doing these light cuz
everyone's like do adventure type V logs
and I started I had no idea what to talk
about and I remember I was just talking
to you at a party I'd like to do I have
no idea what to say about this show and
you were talking about all the things
that were coming up and all the
different sort of themes that go on and
I just said would you be willing to do
this with me cuz I can't think man okay
okay how does were how this wanting to
correct you on this mr. memory okay it
was you and Brad it was after you
recorded the episode with Brad I guess
and I just was babbling about Adventure
Time and you looked to me said oh good
you're helping me
Oh answer and I said okay and you show
up with camera and you watch an episode
and you plop the camera down you just
start talking no scripts no forewarning
no nothing terrible at this I'm not
terrible at this you're just too good at
it hmm
okay you picked it up right away and you
did great at it I know that's that's
pretty much how this whole thing began
was
I was battling by the you know this show
and you're just like oh you're helping
me then and I'm like okay it was fun the
whole thing has just been a blast and
during as much as she cried she had fun
here the whole time
his chooses not to be on air the whole
family's here they're just like now
doesn't even know we've been on camera
like a million times and now we go to
conventions and have people praises but
now we can no praise me please release
me but I really do mean that I mean just
really all you gotta give every time I
mean it's like it looks like we're
having fun here just talking about this
it's like we really are and that really
that's because the environment you guys
create it's just so relaxed and so cool
and you guys just have a ball doing this
do so really thank you guys so much of
me or you're all just you're really gods
iam cool family so thanks for coming I
mean it's every time you come over it's
always fun just to chill with you yeah
and then watching this show it's nice to
be able to share something I love as
much as I do with you and for you not to
be like you're an idiot just go away
what's the stupid crap I do like
throwing it stuffed animals at you and
everything you roll with the punches
just as much as I try to let me so fly
if I did just like what is this
no v-log ruined cotton I know some
people were not happy with
yeah that's I definitely every time you
come over and you know we watch it's
just always fun because also I love even
if I disagree I love your take on each
episode because it's not just the same
if it was the exact same thing I always
thought it would be boring it's yes I
rather even be yeah and it we're never
like exactly the same like we always
have a little bit something different
here or there and I love hearing what
you have to say cuz a lot of times it's
not what I'm thinking
yeah no I yeah I've got you always at
different points of view too and it's
well know really well so um yeah I'm
sure you guys are just like you know oh
god just kiss already but yeah we're
just gonna go ahead we're gonna end this
here
but before we end that we're gonna get
everybody in on this okay so that's
right we're doing you Jori Jori what do
ya say say goodbye Joey I love you Bri
you guys say something say something Bri
say something
aye well done Jason now you what who
what it cats cat Naruto what do you have
to say now at oh wow he talked he
friggin Todd do it again I think that
was you did you see goodbye everybody
like it again come on
y'all come back now you hear why why
wave again we'll make a gif out of it
wait don't shake my butt and that's all